and very often data can tease that out
we can learn how important price is to
the customer how important delivery time
is the customer
how many you know i think a big part of
any marketplace
is understanding that balance of supply
and demand and how to
yeah just like forecast it but also act
against it
peter fishman thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders how are
you today
doing well calling from california
i'm in san francisco san francisco
lots to cover and let's get into it a
fascinating fascinating journey i don't
know how many more people i've had in
this show that have have
so many different experiences as you've
had
i i even have to open it up next to me
in order to read it which i have i don't
think i've ever had to do that before
all the way starting from studying
economics at
london school of economics to doing your
bachelor also at duke
university of california berkeley doing
your phd
and then you're moving to narrow
economic consulting
google philadelphia eagles the pantheon
group
play dom economist and walt disney
director of analytics at yammer
principal data science manager at
microsoft vp of analytics and growth at
zenithfit an amazing company a head of
analytics at open door
a chief bacon officer at bacon hot sauce
you'll have to explain to me what that
is
and most recently your chief strategy
officer of
ease a company that a lot of our friends
in california will know what it's about
and you'll explain to us soon
and now the co-founder of your own
company mozart data did i get any of
that right or am i completely off
uh it's a nice walk down memory lane but
uh yeah i'll
expand a lot of different companies and
a lot of different uh careers with some
common themes there
i need about 19 minutes of breather
after reading that list
peter what the hell how how does a
person go through a list like this how
does that happen
yeah well so i think you hit on on one
thing i'm an economist by trade
so i did my phd uh in economics
uh in the bay about eight miles east of
where i'm currently living
at uc berkeley it was a really special
time to be in
behavioral economics and applied
behavioral economics
um and i was working with a lot of data
and uh and sort of getting that training
and sort of teasing causality uh out of
a data set and trying to understand
what's driving uh certain things that
are happening
simultaneously is a really interesting
tool set that i learned in graduate
school
and then uh there was there was sort of
this really nice movement
towards using more and more and more
data as it became
more ubiquitous in in tooling and
decision making
and then more and more cost div so that
organizations beyond just the giant tech
companies
could really use uh data to advance
their decision making
and that's kind of um been a common
thread uh of my career
right i mean you can you can literally
see the thread as you're transitioning
from
being an economist and an analyst at
these companies to then
running the analytics and growth but
then transitioning into strategy and
data science right and then most most
recently the company that you're running
now mozart data which we'll talk about
soon
is really helping companies analyze the
data pretty much the work that you've
been doing across about a dozen
of these fantastic organizations but
peter before before we get to mozart
data i'll leave that for the second half
i'd love to pick your brain on
these nuggets and experiences from these
different companies as an economist
what is the role of an economist within
these tech organizations and when i look
at also walt disney i think of it as a
technology company like any other so a
lot of
a lot of larger companies have
economists that
opine on the direction of the economy
because so much of the investment of
people and resources
depends on like basically the bigger
macroeconomic picture
um that's actually not at all what i do
um i an economist
in my mind is about
using an economic tool set to understand
uh data so thinking about uh
kind of some of that training and some
of that sort of micro
economic decision making and how that
impacts
the sort of macro uh vision
of a company so i think a lot of um
what i do though my title is often
economist and though my training is
often economist
i'm just an applied statistician that
happens to have taken some
economics classes so i think with that
yeah so i think there's
the the common theme there is that
economists have a really good way
in my mind of thinking about causality
and prediction
a lot of modeling data right right yeah
yeah of thinking about kind of the
relationship between two things that are
happening
um and and that's because um data used
to be a lot smaller so when i did my phd
i had a giant giant giant giant giant
data set which was about half a million
observations
um today if we saw a data set of half a
million observations
um it would um you know it would be
uh you know of uh you know events that
people
might have picked up in minutes or even
less so
um what used to sort of count as a giant
data set was
was uh you know is now a very very very
trivial
data set and but you know because data
was small
you had to think of really clever ways
of understanding the world and
understanding relationships in the data
and sometimes
that meant things like um you know
describing
um a mechanism a behavior
that would sort of account for these two
things
co-varying with each other and sometimes
that would be actually sort of these
fake experiments that would be existing
in the data they weren't real
experiments they weren't like
scientific method experiments where you
try condition a and condition b
and see which one's the winner which is
you know so prevalent in today's a b
testing and other forms of testing
but rather um things that were sort of
almost a natural experiment that would
occur in the data and you'd have small
data and you'd want to
tease out that causal relationship and
think about it in a deep way
about in what ways is this not a real
experiment
so um so that training i think really
helped as we transitioned
uh at smaller tech companies from
essentially small data to almost
everybody having uh big data due to a
lot of cost efficiencies that have come
up on the data side
that transition from an economist or an
analyst to
running analytics to being head of
analytics
head of growth both at as benefits and
then an open door
what is that how is that transition what
what is the thinking process because to
me it sounds like
it it's a little bit even more dramatic
than being an engineer
to to a head of engineering here you're
really because you're saying economists
it's a thinking of
causality and and what impacts what and
modeling data
to see trends and in one hand you're
modeling you know a subset of the data
as in your
position and it sounds to me like you
know being head of analytics is now
thinking
much more broadly about okay where are
we headed what can we extrapolate from
the data and what can we request from
the engineering
to provide us for the future yeah so my
first year of graduate school i read uh
moneyball
which was okay for many me for many
folks in the analytics
industry that was a very sort of
defining book it's michael lewis's book
on the oakland a's and i was going to
graduate school
just one town north of oakland and um
and then ultimately i became sort of the
money baller
at the philadelphia eagles which is i
use my graduate training
to you know pull out sort of insights
about players and football activity
i love that at the eagles um and
um what i learned there was
really about impact across an
organization which is very often
you know there can be an insight like
it's good to go for two
when you're down by 14 or uh
or it's good to trade out of the first
round or
something that the data clearly or it's
good to go for it on fourth and short
whatever it is
the data might back that out and might
be convincing
in an academic way but there's real
people
and you don't get to really run all the
experiments you want in the real
world and sort of having a big impact
across an organization
is not just about teasing out the
insights and the data but it's also
about kind of driving impact within the
organization
now you know it may happen right exactly
so you had mentioned a few transitions
right
i transitioned from being an individual
contributor
at you know a company like platinum and
disney to
being a you know sort of a junior leader
uh to being a more senior leader and all
of those have different steps different
sort of stakeholders across the
organization
and you do kind of like you said for for
many engineers they transition
from being a great engineer to now
having a role of
managing engineers and there's just such
a different sort of almost skill set
um and the same is true of course in in
data and analytics which is to say
there's a certain skill set which
involves
being able to wrangle a bunch of data
being able to clean or
tease insights out of data or
communicate with data
i think actually i i would actually
probably have the opposite
uh because because with when you're an
analytics leader
you're trying to tease those same
insights out of the data and simplify it
at the sort of cross-functional level so
a lot of those core skills you develop
as an ic though the jobs aren't
identical a lot of those sort of course
skills translate really nicely
interesting what are you enjoying mower
uh well you know obviously i've spent
the last sort of decade of my career um
leading data teams of different sizes
you know
i joined zenefits where i led the data
team of just me
and then ultimately grew it to a very
large team as that company
had a really meteoric uh scale up
and then you know obviously uh most
recently before mozart data i worked at
a company ease
ease is basically a cannabis marketplace
that matches supply and demand it
matches
uh sort of dispensaries with consumers
that want those products
um like any regular marketplace except
for
it's it's just because it you you just
give the definition of what a
marketplace does and it seems so common
that
you know we have a marketplace for
everything for beverages for food for
toys for whatever obviously when it
comes to cannabis and it's still a fresh
thing
in in in many states it's still
something that requires
explanation but i'm sure it was a
phenomenal experience and i've actually
been following the activity of ease
and i love the way that they're
democratizing and regulating the whole
transaction
in the marketplace but please continue
yeah so i mean
i i think actually data plays a big big
role there
um you know i think when you think about
a very highly regulated market
um some of the challenges become
actually addressing that regulation but
doing so really quickly and
understanding what really matters
to your customer right and very often
data can tease that out we can learn
how important price is to the customer
how important delivery time is the
customer
how many you know i think a big part of
any marketplace is understanding that
balance of supply and demand and how to
yeah just like forecast it but also act
against it so
um data plays a huge role in what uh
ease does it was a really forward
thinking
uh investment to you know build out a
strong data capability because that was
you know and you know on some senses
forward thinking on the other
on the other hand it's just us catching
up to other industries you know you
mentioned
sort of uh you know food delivery right
looking you know like many of these as
solve problems transportation obviously
the matching of supply and demand that
uber and lyft do
these are all very solved problems in
those industries and kind of
and what a key world data plays at those
places just being able to map that
to you know a place with a ton of
regulatory
challenges you know this is uh cannabis
i think is uh
has been and will continue to be a
really interesting um
data and managerial problem for for a
while
it's it's pretty inspiring to me that a
company like like he's goes in and
takes an economist and somebody that
runs that heads analytics and data
science teams
and puts in the position of a chief
strategy officer because it really it is
saying something it's saying that
we believe that our core strategy should
be guided by
by data and by by you know the causality
and by a team that
knows how to manage this data and run
the analytics i don't
think that most companies have
necessarily that persona as the chief
strategy officer
yeah i might be wrong but i haven't seen
that that often
so i agree with you but i think the
trend is that
so when you think about sort of
marketing you've traditionally seen a
lot of
cmos but you start to see growth leaders
now growth
tends to be just quantitative marketing
right right now similarly on the
operations side when you think about
solving a problem like
how much demand do we expect to have in
say san francisco on a tuesday afternoon
at 3 p.m
ultimately this is a data problem but
it's also a people problem you have to
have the right number of people
sort of there to you know essentially
connect the supply and demand
so on the one hand to me
that kind of strategy work is ultimately
just data problems but you can see
operations you know business operations
and uh operations just looking more and
more like
data problems and having more and more
savvy data leaders come into leadership
roles in those functions
as well as the expectation for anybody
that's a ceo
that's a vp of operations is that
they're comfortable working
certainly in a bi tool but also having a
good grasp of data and what's
what's happening with their data and i
think that's a perfectly way
into a what mozart data does so having
that grasp having that handle on all
this different data and what you can do
talking a little bit about what mozart
data does and i'm particularly
interested to hear
really tangibly what what insights
you've gained from
you know these years of both being the
data handler and the data manager
transitioning into your
your new baby and mozart data yeah
thanks and it's actually
like you said a very relevant uh segway
because
um what dan my co-founder and i saw
was that there was this growing
population of folks that were really
uh competent and comfortable
and itching to use the data like this
population of business
analysts sales ops marketing ops
business ops
heads of analytics data analysts that
really knew what they wanted from their
data had a great understanding of the
business definitions and understanding
of what data would inform those business
decisions but
getting at that data which is now
getting more and more siloed by all the
different sort of
uh bevy of tools that people are using
people using all these different sas
tools and databases that all
basically silo that data that it's
producing
so there's this sort of imbalance where
the demand for data is growing
really rapidly and the supply we know
where it is but it's hard to get at
you typically have to hire engineers or
data engineers
to essentially enable that
centralization of data and this was
becoming a problem
and more and more companies they hire
folks like me or like dan
to actually go centralize that data so
that it can be used across the
organization
and a lot of that centralizing work is
in my mind
um sort of wrote or commoditized
and you know we would just go from
company to company
you know all the ones that you mentioned
in my career building out
either you know the same stack or
something very very similar sort of
centralizing everything
in a powerful data warehouse a columnar
data warehouse and we decided to
essentially build that as a service so
that
really anybody that's really comfortable
with
data and data thinking and sql could
really
do the data cleaning and the extracting
loading and transforming of the data
that needs to be done
um with their skill set you know with
their understanding of the business
definitions with their understanding of
their technologies
and not needing you know python jinja
dags custom languages to really make all
of
the work that is actually quite
straightforward what data you need
making that available without kind of a
big data engineering lift so what we try
to do
is be the easiest way to onboard sort of
a modern data stack
that's it that's so interesting so what
would it would an
interesting workflow be that let's say
that there's somebody in marketing that
has
a ton of data and csvs that they get
from
somewhere within their company they load
that data to you
you help automatically cleaning it and
starting to
to to see some causality and some models
and then
provide would provide them a framework
for analyzing the data without having to
use
things like like code or data science
well so i want to back it up one step so
you know you've already gotten to a
point where the marketer has that data
in csv form
um i want the marketer to be using the
tools that they're comfortable in
maybe that's you know hubspot or maybe
they're using salesforce or maybe
they're using google ads or facebook ads
and we want to be able for them with
just the credentials just the rights to
be able to use that data
to be able to extract and load that into
a central data warehouse
now they might also have csvs or g
sheets or something like that
which they also want to put in their
data warehouse they want to combine and
clean this all
and transform it all uh in
you know in their data warehouse and
they can do that uh with a platform like
mozart now
going all the way to the end we are
actually not in the bi space so we don't
um you know give you the tooling to go
you know
graphically represent your data and tell
a story with your data which is like i
mentioned
you know from my time you know with the
eagles and then throughout my career a
really important
part of what a great data person does
they tell a story
with the answer and that's not really
what
we provide though we actually really
like giving
customers a good push in the back in
terms of these are core tables
these are core pieces of analyses that
like we see
a lot of folks in the space that you're
in doing so we like to give people
frameworks for um for doing the cleaning
for building their analysis
but really what we want to do is empower
you to get to that point of a central
warehouse
where you can start joining data from
different
tools and we want to really make that uh
available to anyone
i love that peter before we go i have to
thank you
for being generous with your time and
for joining me in this show i have two
last questions that i have
asked first of all chief bacon officer
of
bacon hot sauce now you've been there
for ten years
so i'm guessing this is gonna it's a
little different from the rest
yeah so uh so big and has was a real
passion project
um so actually dan the co-founder of
mozart and i
uh started this hot sauce company uh 10
years ago
um we had the idea that the two best
things in the world were bacon and hot
sauce and we had to combine them
and then we made that a reality uh and
then ran that business
uh for ten years and actually uh we
ended up selling the business
uh and uh starting mozart so
so you know there's like sort of like a
a lie which is to say like you know
there's a story about slack which is
they were
you know a tiny speck and then suddenly
they you know that wasn't going where
they wanted it to go so they
decided to pivot into their chat app you
know we sort of tell the story
it's only partially true which is we had
a hot sauce company that was failing
and that we needed to pivot so we
pivoted into this uh
mozart data company which which is true
insofar as that it's dan and i working
on it
uh together but we're sort of dating
people at our core but also bacon and
hot sauce people also at our core
peter i have to say that i feel like
i've wasted uh 20 minutes here because i
want to go back and just talk about this
this bacon hot sauce company and but
we'll leave that for another episode
in another cycle before we leave peter i
need three words that you would use to
describe yourself
sure so uh number one is like efficient
so i love
uh i love when people are able uh
to make uh great uh 80 20 like
trade-offs
um because so much of kind of the
insight i think
comes in kind of just uh the setup and
understanding of it
um i guess uh another one that i
i sort of uh you know as a single word
it's it's sort of like a pay it forward
but i think one of them there's hyphens
in there yeah sure
so pay it forward is what i found in the
valley is that so much of my growth
can be attributed to folks that i've
worked with both that were above me
uh that worked for me and that were
actually um
i guess horizontal to me so um i think
when you
invest in in having those people
understand uh
either data or how you're thinking about
the data or how you're thinking about
the problem
um that pays huge dividends and then
last you know we have um
a big mentality around growth uh uh you
know at mozart uh
professional growth uh you know personal
growth
all of those things and i think uh
growth you know obviously my career at
parts was working in sort of growth
marketing
but um i think growth is also another
one that's a little bit counterintuitive
which is
the more someone grows it doesn't
distract them from the core of what
they're doing it actually
there's no substitution it actually just
adds more and more and more richness
uh to their capabilities and also their
their willingness to invest in something
so
sort of growth ties nicely with pay it
forward
peter thank you very much this is
wonderful congratulations on your recent
four million dollar seed round for
mozart data i told you right before that
i'm that i'm already upset that we did
this
a couple weeks too late because i wish
we could have gotten in there
but uh but really congratulations and i
love i love your take on things and
and particularly i get it inspired by
people's journeys where
where they become they they experience
these
growing pains over or over lots of
experience over shared experiences
eventually
culminating in this aha moment that they
have internally and then
bring it out to the world so thank you
for the inspiration for that and stay
safe and stay healthy
same to you enjoyed it